I've got a game for you today we're
gonna play around would you rather so
briefly choosing between the two options
and then telling me why you would choose
one or the other okay first one here
would you rather screw up every single
take yourself or have somebody else
screw up your best take oh my god all
right let's see every take myself or
have someone screw up my best I would
rather have someone screw up my best
take because I would hate to be the one
screwing everyone else up I feel bad
about everything so I'm right there with
you would you rather do performance
capture or wear a ton of prosthetics
Wow these are these are hard I would
rather do neither but if I had to choose
I would rather do performance capture
because the press gettin the prosthetics
is one thing getting in and out of the
prosthetics is another thing yeah I
could do the acting but if you could if
you called me in four or five hours
early to have to put the prosthetics on
that would be a problem understandable
actually in that case would you rather
work on a set with no food or no
caffeine oh I don't really drink
caffeine so that's easy for you I like
my biggest vice in the world would you
rather have to run throughout an entire
scene or eat for an entire scene run
easily because when you start eating in
a scene and you're on your 20th take you
very often regret it nobody thinks about
that no it's the truth
I feel like the only place to go from
there is would you rather have to fake
sneeze in a scene or fake vomit on the
scene we're faking both thankfully yes
yeah I mean I was gonna say if you said
real vomit I wouldn't want to do that
but faking fake vomiting I don't think
that's that hard
um but fake sneezing is not hard either
so I say fake sneezing that's impressive
I always think fake sneezing is too hard
so I'm like I don't know don't they just
do the tube thing anyway what's the tube
thing like where they put a little tube
and I'll just shoot you from the side
for the bow for the vomit oh yeah that's
true easy enough would you rather play
the hero or the villain the hero it's
close but I would rather play the girl
okay I feel like you get a nice little
mix in this one though yeah he's got
like a little bit of sass to him yeah if
I had to choose I would choose hero but
I like
a little bit of both you know because it
makes life interesting not in the would
you rather format right now but just
because I'm constantly talking about it
because I greatly appreciate original
storytelling but I also value the idea
of keeping a story alive through remakes
for different generations so what is it
about Hellboy in particular that makes
it a worthwhile remake I think it's just
the way that we're approaching this one
the fact that you know we're leaning
into an r-rating and it's a pretty hard
are actually kind of harkens back to the
comic book and the the spirit of the
comic book and what might create it so
there's an authenticity that that this
one has because of the rating jumping
off of that would you rather see another
remake of Hawaii five-o or a remake of
lost assuming that they were both done
well I would say lost I like that answer
let's say they recast you in that loss
remake but you could choose any other
role you want who would you choose and
why it's hard to say because I have such
associations with the actual people and
like I would not want to I would not
want to put them out of a job and and I
liked my character as well but maybe
Sayid I like to say I eat I thought he
was kind of a badass I would be open to
that
who knows ten years down the line maybe
you